vous avez vu cette arnaque au sosie
incroyable alors il y a quelqu'un qui
qui pensait être payé Hélène musk pour
quand même 30
000 30000 dollars 30000 francs 30000 €
pardon les Français c'est fini il y a
longtemps
sur le papier c'était c'était une bonne
idée et au final et ben c'était une
grosse arnaque alors c'est elle est
moche qui débarque sauf que et ben c'est
pas une autre affaire
il est super bien fait quand même
non c'est pas le reste c'est un sosie
franchement moi
c'est pas lui bah non regardez mais ça
n'a
rien il y a quelque chose c'est bien sûr
qui est en bas à droite là
bah oui mais ils n'ont rien à voir hein
alors évidemment on a on a on a
recherché des sosies de stars on a
trouvé le sosie d'Élisabeth borne
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on a retrouvé de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
[Musique]
là
quelque chose
[Musique]
pas mal on a trouvé le sosie le sosie de
Jean-Pascal
qui me ressemble
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a quelque chose
c'est quelle équipe c'est Barcelone
d'Espagne grand joueur grand joueur très
talentueux c'est vrai qu'il me ressemble
un petit peu
[Rires]
ou dans le talent peut-être un peu des
deux je sais pas alors on a retrouvé
également le
sosie de Messi Messi mais non
pour jouer dans un club qui joue que
chez lui
en Arabie Saoudite
euros par heure 7 jours sur 7 24 heures
sur 24 ça veut dire il dort en 1h il a
coûté
si on lui propose
Ronaldo
Benjamin alors 500 millions par an alors
ça me fait vraiment beaucoup rêver
mais pas que moi
tu te dis que chaque chaque année tu
fais deux fois et demi la grosse
cagnotte de l'Euromillions
[Applaudissements]
de Koh-Lanta
2004 vous devriez
pas une petite vanne au bain marie par
exemple au bain-marie ça va l'aimer mais
si mais non
on a retrouvé le saisie
des fois je pense au saisie et saisie
sosie il y a pas de masses hein
elle est encore régalée
j'aurais dû la rencontrer plus
avant patoche
non mais très très joli tu es très jolie
aussi
de Gilles pas mal
ce n'est pas mal regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]